ah so i did a live stream last night
she's up to no good she's going to pull
something out of there
and then she's going to steal it and
play with it
she's contemplating is it worth it
[Music]
okay
diffused bomb defused and in the stream
i talked about the theme for this month
it's optimization october i've wanted to
do this for the longest time and so when
a month starting with the letter o
finally rocked up
i had no choice basically what we're
going to be doing this month is
optimizing hazel
let's talk about what that means so
those of you keeping up with the hazel
devlogs have probably noticed that hazel
is coming along pretty well like we seem
to be getting all of these new features
and you're probably wondering
when are you going to start making games
with hazel and the answer is that's
already happening there are several game
projects that are currently being worked
on using hazel however i can't talk
about them just yet but what has
happened is that those projects have
highlighted some of the performance and
usability issues that hazel has now most
of these issues i've been aware of there
are things that i've been meaning to get
back to later because you can only
develop a game engine so fast but some
of them some of them i didn't quite
expect so what we're going to do is
build our own game during live streams
that are going to specifically exploit
some of these issues so that we can then
optimize them and that's effectively
what we started last night i called it
project orange why orange because i just
needed like a code name and orange is my
favorite color so
there we go what's the game cubes
falling out of the sky something like
that it's really quite fun but again the
point of this game is to
create ourselves honestly like a little
test that combines all of the worst
features of hazel so that we can then
like use that as like a benchmark so
that we can kind of measure their
performance work to improve them and
then see the improvement and what i'll
be doing is kind of using that as a
teaching tool to hopefully like document
this process to show the improvement and
how i'm actually able to to do this
optimization one of the hardest things
for me whilst developing this engine is
specifically choosing to do things in a
way that i know i'll have to get back to
later just because it doesn't make too
much sense for me to narrow in and focus
on something at that current stage
either because there are other features
that need to get done or simply because
we just don't know the full extent of
the problem so
why spend time optimizing a solution
that might need to change later but now
we kind of like there are some things
that are more or less
like we're comfortable with them they've
been around for a year we know they're
gonna basically stay the same way we've
learned a lot the whole team has learnt
a lot and we've had some experience from
people making actual games that can show
us like what what's bad and what needs
to change also when i say optimization
the word optimization and what it means
in the scope of this month it's not just
simply optimizing performance so
reducing something from taking two
milliseconds to one millisecond that's
not that that's not the full picture i'm
talking about optimizing everything
optimizing your whole life not just
performance so i'm also talking about
optimizing like the usability of hazel
so in other words if you want to achieve
a particular effect or make something in
your game maybe there's an easier way
for you to do that maybe there are
certain features even certain small
features that are simply missing that
would make your life easier so that you
wouldn't have to kind of go through the
work around to make that happen a few of
those have popped up throughout game
projects but then there's also like all
of the code
the code in certain areas is quite messy
it's not very well documented and it's
it's probably probably has some bugs in
it let's be honest but basically there
are a few things that i've written down
here as to what exactly needs to be
optimized and this is more from like a
performance perspective so the first
thing is the renderer there are a lot of
things there that we are not really
doing correctly and i mean we'll
probably discuss them more like in
videos later on this month but just know
that like specifically the renderer
needs to be optimized uh also we want to
be able to do instanced rendering so at
the moment if you are rendering five
cubes you just render them as like five
separate draw calls whereas it's
possible to kind of be like hey the
geometry is the same so we can kind of
optimize that use case because that's
actually quite common also because our
renderer literally has like no
optimization at the moment meaning
there's like no culling of objects
there's like no sorting we end up with
like a lot of overdraw and a lot of
other needless stuff that gets submitted
when it shouldn't be there's also a
bunch of like other low-level rendering
things which we'll get to assets and
memory usage ah we don't i don't think
we even unload assets ever at the moment
apart from like maybe if you unload the
whole scene so in other words once you
load an asset it's there for good we
don't really manage memory at all i mean
i've got 32 gigs on my
it seems to work that's not good the
scripting runtime so the way that
c-sharp scripts work at the moment
especially when we want to instantiate
prefabs and a lot of them during the
runtime of a scene that can get quite
slow and i've actually looked at like
profiling results in the past and i know
that that's a bit of a bottleneck so
we'll also have to basically probably
explore the entire script engine runtime
and finally
finally in terms of performance
the big thing you've all been waiting
for
[Music]
multi-threading hazel has been designed
in a way where multi-threading should be
relatively easy to make happen so from
the ground up i've kind of built it with
that architecture in mind so that it
wouldn't be a complete disaster to try
and switch a single threaded engine to a
multi-threaded engine however as it
stands right now we only have a single
main thread
for basically everything in the engine
except for audio so audio i think has
two threads audio being done on another
thread that's that's pretty obvious
that's already done but the main engine
and the way that it operates everything
is on a single thread so all of like the
asset loading all of the scripts all of
the physics is done on the main thread
and all of the rendering is done on the
main thread that is
that has to change because computers
obviously have several cores which we
can take advantage of and so
specifically what we're going to be
doing is moving the entire cpu side of
rendering so all of the vulcan related
code a lot of the rendering related
calculations as well that have to be
done mathematically all of that stuff is
going to move on to its own thread so
we're going to have a main thread and a
render thread and then from there we can
like branch off using a job system into
many other kind of job threads basically
if we need to that's going to be quite
exciting because again i have been
wanting to do that for so long but it's
just one of those things that's a little
bit hard to justify because performance
has been surprisingly fine for a lot of
things but now that real games
quote-unquote real games have have
started being made with hazel that kind
of you know not scaling very well on the
cpu side we're really beginning to see
that because in a lot of the stuff that
i've seen at least the gpu seems to be
keeping up fine gpu times still quite
low but the cpu seems to be the
bottleneck so we're definitely gonna be
able to optimize that by moving that
rendering code to another core so for
all of those optimization features i
know all of you guys are really
interested in that stuff so i will be
i'll be trying to make as many videos as
possible on those topics throughout this
month i'm probably going to do like a
weekly vlog i'll try and kind of
summarize everything that's been going
on i mean honestly i'm going to take
this opportunity this month to just
optimize my life as well not just hazel
so i'll kind of try and take you along
for the journey but as i mentioned there
are also other things not just
performance that we want to optimize so
there are some features that are simply
missing for example at the moment we
don't really have a way to render
transparent materials in hazel so if you
want something to kind of fade out you
can't really make that happen we like
technically support that but there's no
like proper way of doing it after the
opaque pass or anything like that so we
need a way to render transparent objects
that just has to be done and there's a
bunch of other usability things that
i've written down here such as like you
know when you click on the camera it'd
be nice to see like a little picture in
picture so that you can see like what
the camera sees as you move that around
in your scene in the editor we don't
have that be nice to include that and
there are also some issues with the
current mesh workflow kind of system
that also need to be improved so yeah
that's basically the plan for this month
it's going to be all about optimization
i'm
happy to announce that i won't be really
working on any major features in hazel
this month i can finally take a break
from that take a step back and optimize
what we already have if you guys have
been accumulating a large amount of
performance and tech debt in your own
projects i also encourage you to maybe
take a step back and spend this month
along with me
just optimizing everything and if you're
not happy with how you're living your
life and how you're structuring all of
your projects and work around your life
your work-life balance maybe all of that
kind of stuff
this is also the time to kind of take
care of that so yeah optimization
october let's make it a thing i'll see
you guys in the next video goodbye
[Music]
you